[Applause]
so we were both we were thank you so as
you were at the tree lighting as well
that's the most recent place we were at
the same place right did you have did
you have a good time I had such a good
time it was so much fun I think I I
think it was like my eighth year doing
it and by the way I you were awesome by
you look beautiful in that white coat
thank you it wasn't mine my stylist it's
actually Michaela my stylist and she was
I was supposed to wear dresses and last
minute I was like oh hell no no I was
thinking about because it was so I felt
like cryotherapy out there it was so
cool how said I was like oh how's she
singing oh I was very terrified yeah
yeah and then I was just like Lord if
you love me at all just like I'll take a
few notes off key but if you could just
kind of keep me in line most of the time
it was really funny M was cool too I
cried though the tree I've never
experienced it physically in person like
being turned on and in and I didn't
realize it was going to happen it's so
beautiful it is beautiful the spruce
they call it with the spruce it looked
like we were in freaking hooville it did
right yes I always say it feels like
we're in inside a snow globe right there
it's like a Christmas movie it's awesome
and it kind of officially kicks off the
Christmas season so that was awesome I
know Savannah and hod were laughing at
me because they were like are you crying
and I was like yes it's like it's so
beautiful anyway so do you have any
family H holiday traditions that y'all
do I mean you know we have the the
family come over and they everyone kind
of hangs out at Casa Lopez and my wife
being Italian and US of course being a
Mexican a lot of food good food hanging
out so we're eating a lot Dr L again
just like Annie invite me over I'll come
over do it it's a big party so I love
Italian and Mexican food Doby Diego did
it again when we went canoeing I told
him to wait for me at the bank I thought
he knew I meant the River Bank not blank
what did you say I'm just going to say
Money Bank the money Bank yes that of
the financial time go go what did you
say Yes um I said side
Bank side Bank not the River Bank uh but
the side Bank when you be at Wells Fargo
and you go cheat with Bank of America
that's you're a side bench okay huh all
right not a match not a match but but I
appreciate the guest I love it we're
back with Mario Lopez
y'all
so it's like a dream job for me I love
games so much you're H love games I love
games too explain this one so this is a
lot of fun so I I give um the
contestants like sort of funny clever
fil in the blank uh sort of questions
and they have to try to match uh their
partner and guess what they're going to
say they get points and whoever has the
most points at the end wins and so we
have like a couple regular contestant I
say regular because we have some Comics
too to kind of help punch it up and
stuff but it's funny and it's fun oh I
love and there's nothing better than
giving away money you give away money to
people it's the best oh my god it feels
so good so we have another thing in
common we both love sneakers I love
shoes you have a new shoe line I'm so
excited about this uh Kelly look I'm
rocking them right
now the Croc The Croc versions you know
they're they're lightweight and and
comfortable and stylish you could dress
them up dress them down with a suit and
best of all they're affordable not going
to break the bank which is really cool
so really excited about the shoe line we
got all kinds of styles that are coming
out so good stocking stuffers right for
out there and also excited because we
just came out with a new flavor of
tequila a crystallin we have so much in
common I brought some for your staff too
I brought cases for your staff to as a
house GI but oh we got oh look at here
this St on point right
here this is the
you down for a shot yes see this way
it's
somewhere we'll do a little one we'll do
a little one okay baby shot like your
modelito modelito very good I like your
espanol oh I feel sexier I say salute
okay Sal all right here
go pretty smooth right that's clean you
like that yes good cuz sometimes I go
like you know after it no that's really
good yeah she took a pause I was like
uhoh I wanted to no I wanted to take the
moment that's very clean yeah you took
that like a chair oh my God and it's
warm and it's warm I could have used
this the the tree exactly I was just
going to say so wait what are your
thoughts I can't believe this I'm kind
of angry about it but I heard you just
turned 50 whatever genetics go but you
look incredible but thank but I feel
like I feel like my life gets better the
older I get what's funny is you you said
you just turned 50 and then I heard the
audience go no
I know it's D I'm not dead no I'm not
dead they're they went uh cuz they're
offended like well you can't lie about
your age anymore because you know people
just Google you now back in the day you
be able to lie but now you can't because
they'll just Google you but um it kind
of messed with me a little bit I was a
little bit Bumm to be honest and kind of
afraid I don't know why and then I just
kind of leaned into it because I was
like it beats the alternative right not
making
it exactly and and now you know I I like
it it's it's it it is what it is hitting
the fifth level so I'm excited I think
it's a blessing age because not
everybody gets to grow old you know what
I'm saying so it's like and 50 is so
young now what I say 50 is a new 30 no
it is because scientifically we're
living longer yeah ex you know it's a
trip turning 50 it marked my 40th year
in entertainment business because I
started as a little kid as a 10-year-old
which is wild do you think you'll ever
retire or you just love being busy I
want to be like the Latino Dick Clark
and just keep going I love that you said
Dick Clark and
not I don't want to keep I love it so
what so what's new on ex's Hollywood
right now what's happening oh well we're
just uh about to kick off award season
so we just off get so which is nice get
red carpets and stuff up it's fun now
because yeah Co it kind of was taken
away for so many but yeah we got the
award shows coming up and it's always
fun you get to talk to the most like you
the most interesting fascinating in a
good mood they haven't lost yet
especially Golden Globes they haven't
lost yet you know it's TV and film so
everybody's happy yeah yeah that's I
catch them in the beginning yeah exactly
exactly all right everybody you can see
Mario Access Hollywood check your local
listings for where to watch and his new
game show is called blank slate it
premieres January 8th on
[Music]
[Applause]
GSN thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home